time so without further Ado please
welcome smriti our first speaker and we
are really excited to hear about the
spread of misinformation and how NLP can
help in that respect and what we can do
so please
the floor is yours
hi everybody thank you so much for being
here uh by the time I share my screen I
do have to give a disclaimer that I did
not know that the talk is like for 45
minutes I thought it's like for half an
hour so it's probably a little like I
could have added more content but I
didn't know so more time for discussions
and questions and so on so no problem at
all
perfect perfect
question in terms of uh I'm sorry to
interrupt you uh would you prefer
questions uh during your presentation as
they pop up in the chat or like people
interrupt or you prefer to have all the
questions at the end
uh let's hold the questions to the end
because like you said there'd be a lot
of time for discussion because this is
like 15-20 minutes tops I thought it was
like one of those formats because I
spoke at Pilot on Google previously and
there we had like 20 minutes talk in 10
minutes q a so I thought so there to be
honest I I think works better because it
leaves space for so no worries Okay cool
so at the end
mm-hmm
okay so you can see my screen right
yep
yep okay so hi everybody I'm going to be
talking about a really Niche and under
explored topic that um I've come to
learn about very recently myself and
that is gendered his misinformation
right and I'm also going to tell you a
little bit about how I think NLP can
help uh there's not this is very very
underexplored as a concept there's not
much existing research on this but this
is why I thought it would be like a
useful plaque like platform to share
this here because we have so many uh in
like you know brilliant people here who
can probably help work towards solving
this problem
so over the next 15 minutes I will be
covering the following topics firstly
I'd like to start off with the concept
of like you know what is gendered
misinformation how do we understand it
and I'm also going to point out how it's
different from gender disinformation
which is
um even if the term is not that well
known the concept is definitely much
more you know known and mainstream
especially like you know in the last few
years
uh and I'll give some examples of gender
disinformation and then we'll move on to
you know identifying gender Health
misinformation preventing it identifying
how it spreads you know discussing the
research agenda that is you know uh a
part of this problem statement and then
whatever limited existing literature
there is on this I also have like you
know a couple of papers that are not
mine but relevant to the issue so like a
related work survey kind of thing
so that's what I have in mind for right
now but yeah let's get started then uh
so gender disinformation to start off
with is a subset of online or gendered
abuse that uses heavily stereotyped
narratives and sometimes even sexually
charged images to defame women and push
them out of the public sphere this is
very commonly seen in politics I am sure
you know no matter which country you are
from or no matter you know what your uh
sort of background is you all of us
almost would have seen this happen
especially towards you know female
journalists and female politicians uh
this is very gender disinformation as a
concept is very targeted right on the
other hand gendered misinformation is
often you know unintentional and it's
basically the unintentional spread of
false or substandard information and
even though it's like unintentional it's
very widely spreading especially post
the covid-19 pandemic uh and this is
because as uh what happened is that with
this new sort of focus on health care
and you know the existing pre-existing
gendered biases and stereotypes I feel
like maybe that's why this issue has
become more and more relevant over the
last two years especially and while
gendered misinformation can impact
anyone of any gender there is research
to show that it is proportionately
impacts women and non-binary people
so just to be a little more clear on
what uh you know the difference is I'm
sure I just explained this a little bit
but gendered misinformation stems from a
lack of combination of external factors
and internal factors so it's a first of
all it's a very Niche problem right not
even a lot of people know about it so we
need all hands on deck to like you know
first of all spread the word about the
problem itself right and then uh yeah
basically combat it I guess and me and
my colleague at midan we wrote this
really nice article on a woman
International women's day about this
right and most of the this at least this
initial part of the PPT is taken from
this article itself so I put the link
here I will send it to you in the chat
you know towards the end of the college
anybody is interested but I would highly
recommend that you know so people people
who are interested to read it and you
know it's very well explained in that
article
so yeah
uh coming back to like differentiating
between gender disinformation and
gendered misinformation uh gender
disinformation is generally you know
stuff like this we can see this image
over here and like I said right it's all
something that we've seen in the news at
some point unfortunately like for
example when kamla Harris ran for vice
president but there were so many rumors
circulating that she you know either
stepped with somebody to get the job or
you know such kind of baseless
accusations basically and then we have
this famous Infamous tweet of Donald
Trump on the right and these are all
basically examples of gender
disinformation so now that it's clear
what gender disinformation is let's move
toward gendered misinformation and then
towards gender health information Health
misinformation so
gendered misinformation spans topics
including politics economics Health
societal roles and culture and each of
these right including gender
disinformation I personally believe that
each of these are like you know valuable
research problems because again not many
people have looked into this in fact
based on the
related work that I have seen this isn't
even like a known problem especially in
the machine learning and NLP space
so specific to helpness information
which is like the focus of this talk
some common examples include false
claims about vaccines and menstrual
cycles false claims that pregnant people
shouldn't get the vaccine to keep their
baby safe right this is all related to
the recent probate 19 pandemic and
these you know these myths are against
something probably a lot of you have
heard I I myself had to hear the one
about vaccines and menstrual cycles at
home so there's something about
misinformation I mean I was reading it
somewhere as well earlier this is a
little off topic but these kind of uh
misinformed news and like fake news
travels faster than like legitimate and
you know legitimate verified information
and that's another reason why this
problem is you know of such importance
even though we don't it's not such a
mainstream India right now
uh anyway coming back to the topic at
hand uh common gendered health
misinformation topics include you know
abortions vaccines menstrual health
hormone replacement therapy intimate
partner violence also uh STD is gender
affirming care
etc etc we'll see more of these examples
in much more detail now
uh so some examples of these Health
misinformation right includes uh
covid-19 vaccines cause the placenta to
not develop and lower fertility there
was actually an article on this like it
was published online on like some news
forum and then the article had to be
debunked and but yeah like that's the
issue like because of the article itself
so many people would now have this
thought in their mind right and there
are a bunch of them pertaining to
covid-19 right like it causes birth
defects it holds Alters menstrual cycles
it causes infertility uh here personally
like here in my locality we've initially
we've some people were scared of taking
it because they thought that once you
take it like once a young woman takes it
she's not going to be able to have you
know children later so like not even
infertility just you will have your
normal menstrual cycle but you will not
have children later something like that
was circulating so so yeah that's just
like another example of how these things
tend to circulate and apart from
covid-19 there is a lot of you know
misinformation around breastfeeding and
around a watch abortions and another one
is you know the stigma surrounding PCOS
and the gaslighting of how you know
generally there's a lot of social media
information that points toward things
like it's the patient spot like the
person who has PCOS it's there for it
like either they gained weight or they
didn't maintain a proper lifestyle
Choice while the truth at least as I
understand it right based on some
research papers is that it's set like
genetically like you either have it or
you don't at Birth so yeah these are
some common examples and again I'm sure
that you know we have come across a lot
of these in our own daily lives and
maybe even more so yeah moving on
so with this uh the research agenda now
to prevent gendered misinformation
becomes
uh a three-fold problem right the first
one is identifying how these claims
spread by us different social media
platforms and I am working on this
currently but it's proving to be like a
huge challenge like we know that these
claims often spread through social media
platforms right but somehow when you get
down to the nitty-gritty collecting data
for this proves to be a very very very
difficult task I've been trying with
like a couple of colleagues of mine to
find relevant data from different
different social media platforms and I
think up till now all I could come up
with is like 100 popular claims that
were circulated
across social media platforms so the
second very low number in terms of you
know building a data set that you can
train models on or even just you know
being able to identify how much of this
is circulating through social media
because I'm sure it's a lot more than
100 because otherwise we wouldn't be in
like you know this state as we are today
there are articles in the public health
spectrum and in gender strategies uh
spectrums to show that you know people
women especially and young girls like
young teenage girls are very unsure and
are feel very unsafe about the
information that is reaching them uh
there was this article I read while
working on this that said that every one
in five girls in the United States feels
like the the information she gets is
different just because she's a girl
right so this is a huge problem like
because the thing is if you can't
identify
how these claims are spreading you can't
even like you know you can't work toward
building a model you can't work toward
automating it if you can't do it as if
you
so this is also sort of why I thought of
talking about this here I'm open to
collaborations I'm hoping some of you
will reach out after this with you know
maybe willing to work or just you know
just about ideas on how we can collect
this data that is also one of the
reasons I thought this would be a nice
platform to discuss this issue about
but yeah once we can identify where and
how these claims are spreading across
social media platforms The Next Step
would be curating a data set consisting
of these claims and then you know
obviously finding well uh verified
information and you know basically
building a data set at least in the
starting that is like a two class data
set you know either it's gender
misinformation or it is not right and
then the third part and I I personally
believe we are far away from this right
now at least by a few months but it is
developing robust models that can detect
these claims and maybe even identify if
they are misinformation or not right and
actually interestingly enough we do have
some existing literature on that last
part but not about gendered health
misinformation just about like covid-19
misinformation in general and we'll see
that toward like the end of this
presentation but yeah that's about the
resources agenda for this particular
problem statement
and talking a little bit more about you
know identifying the spread of gendered
misinformation there are a lot of
Articles right I've put a couple of
screenshots in the chat uh I'm sorry in
the slide but like see there's this
article that says Facebook post is a
major threat to Public Health and then
there's another article that says social
media Health myths are destroying the
lives of teenage girls this is actually
a really nice article
um but yeah from this article itself
I've taken these right when you go
through like Instagram or Tick Tock the
sort of reals and the sort of content
that you know comes up especially
pertaining to this topic has like
teenagers asking if they can regulate or
predict periods based on their
astrological signs right and then
there's this myth about the birth
control pill causing infertility there
is this spin-off of that myth right like
a slightly different version is that
women who are on the pale me to
periodically take a break from using
contraception to cleanse their bodies as
to not cause infertility at later stage
right so bunch of this stuff and
that's the thing like even though it's
not a largely recognized problem it's
affecting like the wrong people right
it's affecting young women it's
affecting you know young children and
that's not like an audience first of all
nobody should be affected with something
like this but like least of all young
children at least that's what I think
so yeah this is evidence right this is
evidence that there is a spread of
gender Health misinformation but like I
said when you get down to like actually
coding up scripts that can find these
you know posts or these tweets or
whatever like on whatever platform you
are for some reason it doesn't turn up a
lot of results and that's the challenge
right now like being able to develop a
method that can pull out these tweets
from wherever Niche area like tweets or
posts that they're circulating in so
yeah um
now coming to the existing literature
there was nothing uh based on like what
I have researched on so far there was
nothing in the area of gendered
disinformation and there was nothing in
the eye area of gendered help
misinformation or even gender
misinformation like that but there were
a couple of reasons and papers on health
misinformation
and I strongly believe that since
gendered Health misinformation is a
subset of misinformation
we could probably use similar methods if
not the same right
and so that's why I've taken like a
couple of papers that I thought we could
discuss here like you know very very
briefly and you know those who are
interested can read it on their own time
and yeah I mean I I strongly suspect
that to solving This research problem
also the method will be the same it's
just the data that will be a challenge
like obviously not the same I think but
something similar will probably work but
the data collection is like the main
concern right now
so anyways uh coming back to the topic
at hand a paper titled Health
misinformation detection in the Social
Web an overview and a data science
approach uses a few public data sets
available related to health
misinformation and then the authors they
employ this bag of words model to
identify
distinct classes of helpless information
features so they use whatever you know
data sets are publicly available and
even in that paper is it mentioned that
you know this is a very underexplored
area and there is like not enough data
to like you know as would be ideally but
they use this bag of words model to
identify six distinct classes of Health
misinformation features and simply put
this means that these six features are
probably what is going to be able to
help
the model that is being trained to
distinguish between you know what is
misinformation and what is not so these
are texture representation features
right relating to different possible
formal representations of text then
there are linguistic stylistic features
and this takes into account the presence
of different stylistic aspects of text
and then we have something called
linguistic emotional features and this
identifies like emotional character that
transpires from text my guess is here
right and this is just my you know
insight into this but I think that you
know uh
specifically misinformation claims
are going to at least some of them if
not all of them are going to have a
higher content of like linguistic
emotional features right and then
there's this linguistic medical features
that relates to this presence of
specific medical terms within the text
obviously this is like highly relevant
for happiness information and then
propagation Network features takes into
account The Social Network itself and
the way information is propagated on it
and again I think this has to go back to
the fact point I made earlier that
somehow the fake news and like the
unverified claims travel faster than the
verified ones so yeah I found this like
really interesting and I really do
believe that once we can have a data set
like you know useful data set we can do
something similar and at least as a
first step figure out what are the
distinct features to identify gendered
help misinformation I think it'll be
similar to this just based on my
intuition but what we might have more of
right is like something related to
gendered studies or something related to
gender terms because well of the gender
and fitness information I guess but yeah
uh the next paper is the one I've
mentioned a little bit earlier it's
called web search engine misinformation
Notifier extension so that's a mouthful
but yeah it's a machine learning based
approach to identify misinformation
during the covid-19 pandemic right and
they've basically come up with a web
search engine misinformation extension
so I found this really cool because not
only is it you know a novel research
idea it's also
usable and accessible if deployed
correctly right so the engine itself is
called semi next
and a combination of NLP and enables the
semi-next engine to read a user query
from the search bar
classify the veracity of the query and
notify the authentic city of the query
to the user all in real time to prevent
the spread of misinformation so this I
personally love this idea right and for
the proof of concept in the paper at
least the engine was activated when
words from a predefined list of covid-19
related words were found in a user query
and the really nice thing about this is
that the data set they use to train this
engine is publicly available like on
GitHub right
and they actually did use social media
platforms for their inspiration like
Twitter Facebook and they also relied on
a bunch of news articles
and once they had the data set they
trained a number of supervised models
like support Vector machines and uh you
know random Forest knife based decision
tree all these and neural networks to
compare like how each of these models
fared at this task and then the results
finally showed that the artificial
neural network works best with an
accuracy of 93 F1 score of 92 percent
and precision of 92
so on the right here right you can see
that the image is a little bit different
from the other templates and that's
because this is the image in the paper
that describes how their uh web engine
works so if the user query has like a
relevant port and the engine is
activated then the query text is
extracted from the search bar and then
there's a neural network that goes back
and sort of checks whether the you know
the query has some misinformation
content in it and that is where it
predicts the query authenticity and then
it also predicts the authenticity and
displays it in like a message box in
that engine and then uh then you know
the whole process basically keeps
repeating but I really thought that you
know if and when we are able to develop
a data set and train a model for uh you
know the gender helpness information
problem we should definitely try
something like this you know to make it
and deploy it of course to make it like
you know accessible to everybody because
that's when at least I believe that
research is most most useful when it's
like you know actually helping as many
people as possible so yeah
uh yeah that's about it but like I said
if anybody is interested in you know
collaborating with me or anybody is
interested in this problem statement
please feel free to reach out to me I
can put my um you can find my LinkedIn
like it's fairly easy I didn't I forgot
to put in my portfolio link here but
maybe I'll put it in the chat it's if
that's like a good idea thank you so
much and I hope this was like an
interesting topic for all of you too
like you know hear about thank you
hey thank you very much
questions
um I have a question I mean I have
certain questions
um you Illustrated that salad is briefly
like um in a way but if you were to
distill let's say someone approaching
you now like because you investigated
this topic for for a while and you
really focus there if someone approach
to you and say okay I'm um
I'm really listening the topic I'm a
machine learning engineer or a data
scientist and I would love to contribute
but on a technical level what is the
biggest challenge or like a top two top
three of challenges uh that this
particular data science uh approach to
this topic would entail
based on the work I have done so far the
biggest challenge is a data science day
it's more of a data mining challenge at
this point it's being able to identify
where these claims exactly are on the
internet because we know they're like
circulating through certain news
articles and through certain social
media platforms but like I said I have
done a lot of you know extensive
searching on Twitter and Reddit and even
quora and I have not been able to come
up with more than a hundred such claims
across that is including all three
socials
problem
I see I see but given like okay that's a
bit subjective but maybe we're all the
same page like from our subjective
day-to-day interaction with social media
I would say there are way more than a
hundred that you can find you know right
there are more than a hundred I guess
the challenge
yeah yeah how so basically it's a
classic problem how like uh data
curation effort
but have you thought about because it's
the classic problem okay how do we find
the data and how do we curate them like
how do we have a label um label data set
that's always a problem
um
so have you thought maybe of uh an
unsupervised way how to detect let's say
in a in a labeled freeway
SATs
type of content potentially
because
no no go ahead
please interact with you don't yeah uh I
personally hadn't thought of that yet
to step right is because all of the
apis and stuff on like normal you know
3p and pro and stuff this didn't work
out like I said I was maybe thinking of
taking a more crowdsourcing approach but
yeah what you said makes a lot of sense
to and yeah maybe we should try that
um
so
yeah just thinking out loud because
there are some papers that for instance
could could predict from interactions in
Twitter
like followers and tweets and so on so
they construct the social network based
on Twitter
and they could actually do an
unsupervised uh learning uh basically
they were finding groups of users
and they could find clusters like okay
these are the Democrats it was it had to
do with the U.S elections so these are
the Democrats these are Republicans
they're also kind of an in-between
cluster which are kind of undecided
they're a bit of Leaning here and there
so it's like they haven't made that
their minds that that's that was
reflected in their preferences and their
tweets
uh but also interestingly you could also
spot sort of outlier clusters so you had
like these big chunks
in between what I just described but
then you had some satellite extreme
users you know so maybe I'm just
thinking out loud if you could mind
because there are some nice applications
now I don't know mask go Twitter so
maybe the policies have changed I have
no clue but in the past you could mine
with some restrictions Twitter and the
content and you could have kind of a
decent kind of rate limit I mean it took
some time but so you could in principle
mindset information based on hashtags
and then maybe decompose them
based on an unsupervised way these
tweets just
on the text-based moment like maybe a
word Vector similarity or something like
that anyway like I said thinking out
loud
um
there's a question yeah Hans uh uh
yeah so thank you for the speech do you
hear me well
yeah I can yeah okay great so thank you
for the speech I'm not sure if I
understood is it is the topic that you
don't find enough mentions of the false
claims or is the problems that it's the
claims like uh you have maybe 100
different people saying essential is the
same thing and then you want to
categorize them into one claim
I'm not sure if anything so the problem
is this problem itself spans like
um range of domains even in the health
you know Spectrum the problem is being
able to
identify
how they spread like for example right
let me just take an example to like
through like better explain my point uh
this rumor that went around like uh the
covid-19 vaccine causes either in
fertility or Autism menstrual cycle or
does something you're like menstrual
cycle that was very uh you know
internationally spread because a few of
my colleagues in the states heard it I
heard it at home so like it did it did
circulate and it circulated pretty fast
so the and based on how we are
communicating with each other especially
like you know uh
across borders like whatever
geographical borders that you might
consider it follows that you know social
media would have been definitely one of
the factors if not the biggest one right
and
there should be data that shows this
right so for example if I were to go to
Twitter right now and search with some
relevant hashtag like you know maybe
covid-19 vaccine plus I don't know
hashtag pregnancy or hashtag menstrual
Health you would expect a decent number
of tweets to pop up using the API but
but they don't and like I guess that's
the problem
does that make sense yeah yeah sure and
I was thinking because I did something I
did something similar on a very small
scale uh but where we let people
categorize political essentially just
like anything politics and they
categorized it into different uh
categories and and we were quite
surprised that it was very at each point
in time there were very few uh topics
circulating
uh so like one day was essentially two
topics or three topics but then the
month afterwards it was different ones
so it was
so maybe if you have a data that is
collected from many sources at one point
in time you don't get that many data
points uh but it's more like over over
time you will get because you will
sequence them in a way but maybe they I
don't know if you have temporal data or
if you have one point in time data
well because
I think to that extent right the Twitter
API itself like the library I mean the
interface itself has some time Bond on
it like I'm not I don't remember what it
is right now but your right may be
explicitly specifying a broader range of
time could help and yeah that's
definitely a valuable idea so thank you
for that
yeah or maybe like not taking a range of
dates but taking like the first of every
month during two years or something
yeah maybe yeah
that makes sense there's actually this
um unofficial uh API for Twitter it's
called twin right and it's developed by
this like it's a big package basically
and when you use that interface right
let me just put it in the chat here 20.
it it is supposed to at least it because
it's not the official Twitter API it is
supposed to give like a list of tweets
that is like you know
last 10 years last five years basically
yield a huge amount of data right and
when we run this uh interface on
similar kind of queries right we find a
lot of content like the content is in
you know the hundreds of thousands if
not more but the thing is when you
filter through those tweets that this
interface gathers based on your search
words right you don't find a lot of them
uh
relevant I guess like because for
something to be classified as a
misinformation claim it has to be you
know a either actively promoting
something that you can refute using
science or like you know using the
existing knowledge base or it has to be
you know very aggressively like you know
something like maybe covid-19 vaccine
doesn't work just as an example of
helpless information right these things
you can classify as misinformation
claims most of the content right is just
a retweeting of links right or
retweeting of other people's tweets and
I mean that's the thing it's not exactly
clean data I guess it's not exactly good
data usable data I guess that's did that
make sense
um okay if you finished
um we have a question from the chat
Ronnie
um so I read it foreign I might have
missed this slide but what will be the
source of authenticity that's question
one and then he has another one
what's the source of authenticity of
what
that only Ronnie can answer so Ronnie if
you want to step in
is he in the call with regard to the
last slide okay let me pull up the last
slide
oh dark authenticity okay so based on my
understanding of the paper right they're
basically asking what is the source of
authenticity for the web engine so they
use like a bunch of web crawlers to look
at like authentic Health authorities
websites like the who the CDC they had
like a list of like places they check
out and they see like whether the
information can be verified from that
and then they also cross-reference with
uh famous like news uh you know
newsrooms online newsrooms that kind of
stuff to see if uh you know the thing is
the claim the particular query is
circulating a lot and if somewhere it
has been shown on the internet that it's
fake so yeah I hope that answers the
question and question two is do you
think the gendered misinformation
problem could be more geographical or
lingual specific I think it could be
geographically and linguistically
bearing definitely like in different
languages you would have different uh
gendered misinformation claims and again
maybe reason to reason also that's a
good point it would vary a little but
especially right now in today's day and
age right
I don't think they would be that
different right because information is
no longer contained geographically
information transcends Geographic
borders and if information does sadly it
follows that misinformation does too
probably even faster than information
sometimes so it would vary yes but I
don't think it is specific to one
location or one language
no exciting I would expect that the
geographic
um would have like a lab you know there
is an origin of emergency information
and then it spreads when the geography
in the language kind of catches up right
you you know what I mean
um yeah
yeah but
um
I don't think it would be different
necessarily maybe there will be some
small variation so okay got another
country they added something to the mix
yeah
yeah
yeah
it becomes a little bit like that game
then that uh the Chinese whisper game
right like you say something and then I
say something else and by the time it
reaches the end of the line it's just
some very different version of what
originally started but yeah
do we have any more questions
yeah I have one maybe yeah we can wait
but in the meantime I ask this one note
with what uh Daphne said
have you ever
examine how this misinformation spreads
like if there is a specific pattern so
does it spread
through specific hubs in social media
that might be bought or like I don't
know
people like Trump so is it the case so
my opponent
so consider this like we have highly
influential people but influential in in
a in a bad way in that content so is it
the case that the trams of the world
kind of like video on each other so they
really kind of
tweet immediately so like we have Trump
one and Trump too so not to name other
people
and they belong potentially to different
countries maybe they are like political
figures or like uh quote-unquote
journalists and so on
so is it the case that maybe that all
these misinformation spreads through the
fast interactions between this super bad
spreaders let's say or is it something
or that it trickles down first the
community and then spreads to another
you know what I mean so there are
different modes I mean not to complicate
things but at different mode of
communication across networks social
networks in that case
have you ever looked at potential papers
like that look how this type of
information spreads but because I think
that would be very insightful
[Music]
I mean specific to gendered
misinformation I doubt work has been
done on this because gendered
misinformation is a speed that is hardly
explored especially in this ml side of
things but I think there will be
research to show like you know
especially like with the politics
example probably somebody has looked
into this right and it's actually an
interesting uh you know problem
statement in itself but again I think it
needs some starting point like even to
be able to trace like you know who is
saying it you have to be able to
first point out what are they saying
right and again that brings us back to
the first point of having good quality
data even if it's not a lot right like
maybe a few hundred claims that you know
you can identify who has said it like if
you take Twitter for example you will be
able to get uh who tweeted it right and
even if you can get maybe like 300
tweets you can use something like a
Active Learning approach or like I don't
know something like that but again to be
able to understand who is saying
something you need to know what they are
saying so yeah
yeah a lot of Dimensions to consider
absolutely
okay
more questions Maybe
from the chat
no the reason I think yeah so far I have
it open now
okay so I don't know what you guys think
so we have a longer break and then we
join
I guess we can read in 15 minutes
uh we can do that but just in case that
someone
we can definitely do that just just a
thought maybe someone logs in at eight
because that's what is scheduled
and then they have missed like 15
minutes anyway just a thought I don't
know whatever you guys prefer but my
vote would be we start at eight as
scheduled
anyway we can take votes I vote for them
I don't know
I mean
yeah
anyway like I said uh that's my opinion
we can do whatever we want we what we
want
sorry it would work for me it would work
either way so
um
okay
yeah
all right the organizer
all right um so organizers
who is for eight
question is what do we have in our
meeting say what
do we have a Time on our Meetup page
we don't
and we don't then we can start in 15
minutes yeah okay I thought that we have
at the limiter but yeah absolutely then
we start like
10 to 10 to 8. is that good
is that good
Yes sounds good all right so guys see
you 10 to 8 like in